welcome to this video playing Alan Helen
and in August auto if this is something
like a correct pronunciation it probably
isn't okay and try the reversed Grand
Prix and get us always not as if you
manage to get this exchange maybe I
should have waited interesting if I was
interesting that early okay so take
Bishop e6 not sure okay but I want to
take really I could I could try this and
if I have managed to take nope yeah then
I have won a 10-point Queen t7 and
possibly Bishop a three Bishop a tree of
course looks a bit strange but better
better wait for a more opportune moment
at the moment the special bond g2 is not
particularly strong of course so Bishop
a tree only makes sense if you get some
pressure against that say the F porn I'm
trying to to get down first I'm trying
to fix the structure what is this not so
easy for y to get the night to defy if
this is why this is not a bad structure
well let's say the structure which
usually is bad is it not so bad here
okay plus my rock on f7 is nicely
covering this ok let's see I always
thought I could maybe manage to get in
night 2d for myself but this is not so
easy to do I really I really am assess
this incorrectly
okay the IDS night d7c 5v six this was
my original idea but it's so time
consuming I have my doubts that it's
really good he can maybe he not he she
can maybe take also him
hmm yo
hmm this doesn't look good at all I just
played this badly
hmm yeah maybe c-5m prepared ok let's go
here try to make it more difficult to go
for FR at least
maybe I can get this night to e6 hmm
could be an idea night to you six
hmm if is it possible like something
like c6 night retreats at night f6 to
age 5 hmm it's probably far too
ambitious and SSC 5 coming who came come
on like I should have played this google
not quicker more quickly as the the
right way to to use this check huh yeah
it doesn't look look too great I I see
but still if i get to get in 96 to
deform everything's ok
maybe I'm just I'm just about through in
time to do that okay but this this is
not a problem I don't think so and I
also get to the a phone yeah this is ok
now the the traits are who are favorable
for me yeah I have to open follow
look a form sm oh yeah to first prevent
that the easy easy moves I should
prevent like f 6m now I have six I can
take it's no problem
block with the king okay
yeah the check is not really helping me
better take the a file and try rook a3
and stuff to get some attack on my own I
look g3 hmm
okay better better not allow that now
this is also not not bad i can i can do
that just
pushing him
forgot about the smooth
it's a couple of the seventh-ranked oops
hmm really hahaha f7 on the leaderboard
check time warning
oops white worth it sometime Wow she'd
somehow really irritated that girl of me
at the end but um yeah that was this was
really a good position for what she
really outplayed me then it somehow
turned I mean this probably hear Y
should do something else b5 or let's say
this and then check this is really a
doesn't doesn't do the trick I only have
26 now to defend at this Bishop it's not
not so great as well did you just you
should just stay put here Queen Queen
somewhere Queen here I don't know just
just keep the position maybe I can take
on edge for you yeah but white is
clearly better okay and here it's not so
clear anymore and this I think already a
mess is better for black white needs to
do something here to fight for the a
file cannot easily allow the smooth
maybe he and Luke a1 something like that
yeah I've got okay Adam there's already
really this is just a bad plan with
Queen g5 after that black is black is on
top alright hope you enjoyed it thanks
for watching